now let's look into a couple of best
practices that you should apply whenever
you write an action title and here we'll
always have an example and then an
Insight that I want to draw out from
that here the first example is managing
a risk is important for this Project's
success in your mindset is try to avoid
statements like that try to avoid
writing General truths that are pretty
much always correct so of course
managing risks is pretty much always
important for this Project's success
right so for almost every project that
will be relevant so try to avoid writing
things that are obvious really draw out
more insightful things